it's a hard path
the life of a hero
[Music]
people depend on you
even if you were in a battle sometimes
they die
the world is asking who is going to be
the next Iron Man Stark made you an
Avenger
the world needs people like you
hey friends are in trouble there all
along the question is what are you gonna
do about it
superhero stuff
[Music]
I gotta get you guys out of here
spider-man spider-man I work with
spider-man not for spider-man how's it
going everybody it's Warren and we have
a brand new spider-man far from home
trailer today there's a little bit of
new footage and some new dialogue that
focuses on Peter Parker spider-man
becoming the next hero after Ironman has
died so I'll break it all down in this
video but first a reminder to subscribe
to my channel at the 450,000 subscriber
Mike I will be picking three winners for
the Marvel Legends series item giveaway
so this opening dialogue of Mysterio
talking to Peter Parker is actually very
important he's talking to Peter and he
says it's a hard path the life of a hero
people depend on you even if you win a
battle sometimes people die and right
when he says that it shows the Iron Man
mural so like I've said in other
spider-man far from home trailer
breakdowns in this movie we're going to
see Peter Parker really really struggle
with the loss of Tony Stark and what's
happening in the scene is that Quentin
Beck Mysterio is trying to take
advantage of the fact that Peter is
mourning the loss of Iron Man so this
really comes down to who exactly
Mysterio is he is a trickster he is an
illusionist
Mysterio's whole deal is that he wants
to be the big hero that everybody loves
Mysterio wants to be the new Iron Man he
does not want spider-man to be the new
biggest hero this has always been how
Mysterio has acted he wants spider-man
out of the way so he can step into that
spotlight as the hero that everybody
loves so his first tactic is to act like
a hero and get close with spider-man
it's already mentioned that if Tony
Stark was like the father to Peter
Parker Mysterio is like the cool uncle
so in this scene it seems like Mysterio
is trying to give Peter advice but
really what he's trying to do is to get
Peter Parker to quit being spider-man
that way if Peter decides to not be
spider-man anymore Mysterio can be the
hero that everybody loves and he can get
all the fame in the glory and we've
heard from other trailers that Peter
Parker kind of just wants a break he
doesn't want to be spider-man at this
point in time he's been ignoring Nick
Fury's calls he tried to leave his
spider-man suit at home but Aunt May
packed it for him and we've heard him
say that he just kind of won
to tell MJ that he likes her so Peter
actually does want to put this superhero
stuff aside at least for the moment and
Mysterio is trying to exploit that so he
probably is successful on some level at
some point in time in the movie
spider-man probably does hang up the
mantle just for a brief moment but then
Mysterio ends up being the bad guy and
then of course spider-man has to come
back and defeat him it's a pretty
classic story of spider-man and Mysterio
so again it seems like Peter sort of
hangs up the mantle at least for his
vacation but then Mysterio threatens his
friends somehow because we hear happy
say your friends are in trouble what are
you gonna do and Peter Parker says
superhero stuff so of course by the end
of the movie Peter is sort of going to
snap back into it he's going to realize
that Mysterio is bad and the world does
need the new Iron Man and that is him so
that does it for this new spider-man far
from home trailer like I said not too
much new footage but some very important
dialogue let me know what you think
about this new footage and let me know
how excited you are to finally see
spider-man far from home in just about a
month and again at the 450,000
subscriber mark I will be picking three
winners and each winner will get one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection and then I'll be doing a huge
giveaway at the 500,000 subscriber mark
as well as an Instagram and Twitter
giveaway soon so you can follow me on
there if you want also if you enjoy
other non Marvel related content you can
check out my other channel cosmic
culture as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your